a second plane hit the second tower
America is under attack cameras capture
the moment as the president absorbs the
news President Bush had no poker face
and he couldn't fake anyway when he's
moved that everybody sees it he doesn't
have much Kyle ladies and gentlemen this
is a difficult moment for America I
unfortunately will be going back to
Washington after my remarks
President Bush leaves Florida but does
not return to Washington
fearing the White House may be a target
The Secret Service instead flies the
president to Barksdale Air Force Base in
Louisiana he was very persistent about
trying to get back to the White House
and I was one of those who was reluctant
to go back until we understood what was
happening in Washington the Secret
Service hustles Vice President Dick
Cheney to an underground bunker from Air
Force One
President Bush telephones Cheney and
declares somebody's going to pay I heard
him first used the term that we are at
war early that morning when we were on
Air Force One
the president returns to Washington and
addresses the nation that night he
declares the u.s. is at war we stand
together to win the war against
terrorism but at war with whom remains
unclear Saddam Hussein's name was
mentioned almost immediately by some
colleagues in the Department of
Defense's maybe we ought to take a look
to see if he might have been involved in
this the u.s. suspicions the Iraqi
dictator may have played a role in 9/11
arises from a decade of conflict with
Saddam's regime US and other Western
intelligence agencies have documented
Saddam's support for terrorist groups
they also suspect he possesses chemical
and biological weapons of mass
destruction or WMD and they fear he may
have a nuclear weapons program as well
germs and chemicals and dirty bombs and
all the rest of it the mecca if you will
for WMD and the infrastructure for
production of more WMD was in Iraq
but the CIA sees no link to Saddam they
identify Osama bin Laden and his
terrorist network al Qaeda as the
culprit
there was a a real sense that Iraq was
not responsible for 9/11 that there was
no strategic relationship between Iraq
and al Qaeda four days after the attacks
President Bush meets with his National
Security Council like Camp David to
formulate a response
despite the intelligence about Al Qaeda
Deputy Secretary of Defense Paul
Wolfowitz repeatedly focuses the
dialogue on Iraq Wolfowitz defense
secretary Donald Rumsfeld in others have
long argued the u.s. should remove the
dictator from power they didn't wait for
9/11 to become interested in Iraq during
the first months of the new Bush
administration they were advocating that
we go to war with Iraq and in the wake
of 9/11 the secretary and his deputy see
their opening
you